an interpreter who has failed in
uh in some sort of endeavor um may be
a better ceo of the next company that
they start
than somebody who simply had a good idea
and is
doing a startup welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford sometimes one needs to go on a
long trip to discover where he came from
meet arya greene chief strategy officer
at gigawatt global
and author of my israel trail arya is
the author of my israel trail
finding peace in the promised land about
his hike on schwill israel
the 700 700-mile israel national trail
and meeting personal challenges
and is the chief strategy officer at
gigawatt global a renewable energy
platform for africa based in jerusalem
arya is a former senior advisor to
nathan charonsky in israel's prime
minister office and was the founder and
director of media central a jerusalem
project of honest reporting providing
services for the foreign press
in the region arya green welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you for joining me
thanks very much michael uh
this is going to be a different episode
than we usually have usually we talk
about it you know a technology industry
we talk about it as startup
but really the point of this show is is
extracting those nuggets of leadership
and entrepreneurship
that can come from anywhere and and you
know i as a technology enthusiast i
usually look for them in the technology
sphere but really any
leadership or a any form of leadership
that is in the technology sphere first
comes out from our personal experiences
throughout our life
right and so i'm really excited to talk
to you about your insights
from in this context i'm excited to talk
to you about
your israel trail the 700 mile trail
and and your journey and your insight so
aria please tell me a little bit about
yourself and and
let's start going well thank you michael
thank you for inviting me
to be on the show i don't know how much
of a of a leader
i am but i like the idea of sharing
whatever modest uh wisdom that i've
gained in my life
experience i actually did work for many
years in high tech
in business and i actually today not in
high tech but so
i'm helping to run a company which is
uh bringing renewable energy to africa
and that's also i've learned a lot of
lessons
there uh infrastructure related um
the issue of doing business in
developing countries and of course
renewable energy but
um yeah i i hiked the israel trail the
israel national trail
which uh as you said is about 700 miles
long
from the tip of the country in the south
on the red sea up to the border of
lebanon
north and i did it uh all by myself
uh really in uh over the course of two
months yup over the course of two months
with a
with a 25 pound pack sorry 25 kilo
pack a 50 pound pack on my back um
and i i you you may know this is kind of
the the cohort that that hikes the trail
here in israel
is usually kind of the post army you
know young
21 year old cohort i was 51
i was 51 when i did it i did it for a
very specific reason i was kind of
looking to
clear my head as somebody said to me and
get out
after uh unfortunately a devastating
divorce something that
i hadn't i hadn't wanted was not my
choice and uh
this was really a way for me to almost
literally move on
with my life and i learned a lot of
lessons on those two months
and really lessons which which came from
the hike itself the physical hike that
really helped me
to to meet the personal challenge that i
was facing in terms of the pain and the
and the uh and the the difficulties of
the
of the divorce and that's where they
that's where the book came from it was
kind of a two books in one like a book
about the hike itself
and the geography and the history and
the people of israel
and then these five lessons that i
learned and to to meet personal
challenges that i that i learned along
the way
i i just love this introduction and i
love the idea of the five lessons so
my biggest suggestion is let's run
through these five lessons and share
with me some of the
personal insights that you've gained i
think that it's it's it's always
incredible
listening to you know the personal
challenges that you've gone through and
and how you came on the other side with
some insights that are general to
problem solving and to tackling these
personal challenges that aren't
specifically to your
situation but they can be helpful in in
a multitude of situations and i'm
so i'm first excited to use it to use
the insights you're about to share with
me on my own challenges
and hopefully they're also relevant for
others so please go ahead
thank you for saying so and and i have
to preface anything i say
uh with the remark that the wisdom that
i that i
gained on this hike as i said came from
some of the physical challenges and
emotional challenges that i was facing
but
really it's based on the time the time
honored wisdom
of our sages in terms of jewish
tradition and our heritage and
and philosophers and uh and therapists
and others
uh over the course of uh of the last two
generations
um and and that includes uh
um victor frankel's book uh man's search
for meaning
yes and uh and so many others that i was
exposed to leo buscaglia
down at ucla in our native california
who wrote a lot about love about
acceptance so
the five lessons it's kind of hard to
sum them up but i can and i will in just
five words or five phrases
obviously uh the book itself each each
element each lesson has at least one
chapter if not two as i hiked through
the silence of the desert and the hills
of the uh
of the north of israel and along the
coast and up to and back from jerusalem
and but those five lessons i can sum up
relatively simply
the first was humility uh this kind of
sense of modesty
especially trudging hour after hour day
after day through the
the silence of that desert in the negev
in the south of the country
um understanding the importance of
recognizing
our place in the world not to minimize
our own challenges and problems but just
to put them in perspective in the
perspective of sorts
humility was the first lesson and the
second was
acceptance and i can't go into the whole
story we've done enough time but there
were a number of times
i described in the book that i was on
the side of a cliff
and i didn't know what to do and i had
to make a decision and
and i basically said to myself are you
accept it
here's where you are on the side of a
cliff you need to now figure out what
your next steps are going to be and so
that acceptance that
recognition of reality uh was the second
lesson that that helped me for instance
recognizing
i never expected to find myself divorced
here i am
figure out what you're going to do next
the third
lesson was was one of gratitude i
developed a keen sense of appreciation
for just
everything for the privilege to be able
to hike this land of israel
you know to the privilege of living here
in israel after 2000 years of our
peoples
being dispersed and now coming back to
our ancestral homeland
and the appreciation that i had for my
friends and family who supported me
in the difficulties that i was facing
and the truth is even at the end
uh as counterintuitive as it may sound a
sense of gratitude for my former wife
for the life
that we had built and lived together for
30 years three children
building a home and a life in a
community here in israel
so that was the third lesson gratitude
the fourth lesson was probably the most
difficult for me
uh and can be i think for many others
and that was forgiveness
the not just intellectual sense that my
wife is an adult woman
she can make her own choices i have to
respect that
but more of a heartfelt kind of gut
level sense of forgiveness of the
hurt that she caused by breaking up her
family and the pain that she caused
me and i i learned that lesson
from a number of different elements on
the trail which again i can't go into
details but one of them was walking
along the northern border with lebanon
and
and thinking about the arab israel
conflict and how
a sense of forgiveness is going to be a
very important part of any
steps that we want to take towards real
peace in our region
right both of these communities are
going to have to learn how to forgive
each other for our either
past actions or or whatever grievances
or perceived grievances
there there might be so those are the
fourth
the four initial lessons and those four
kind of combined together this humility
and acceptance of what is and gratitude
for the blessings in my life
and a sense of forgiveness for those
who've hurt us
kind of combined together on the last
week or two of the trail when i was
heading home
and i recognized you know i had a goal
the goal was to hike
the trail and i had a goal every day to
get to the end of that
whatever that segment was that day and
get to where i was supposed to sleep or
camper where i
had put some water to wait for me in the
desert
and obviously my wider goal was to was
to get on with my life as i said to
find ways to to move ahead but i
realized there a week
before i arrived home okay now what
i've got to have some sort of and that's
where the ideas of of
goals of having a a a
a real and concrete set of objectives
whether personal or professional
um to to be a a better father to
to find new love to open my winery
having been a
vintner i've made wine for as a hobby
the last uh 20 years or so here in
israel
to change careers and move into
renewable energy with my friend joseph
abramovic instead of
continuing the work that i had been
doing in the government and
uh and in the nonprofit sector and in
the business world
and so that idea of having a sense of
uh of goal of purpose that brings me
around to
to victor frankel's incredible work
uh the lessons he learned of facing his
own challenges which of course was
holocaust um where he discovered and
developed a whole theory of
psychotherapy called logotherapy
where he discovered that people with a
reason to live within a
with a goal that they set for themselves
were more likely to survive
yeah in the camps and so and so that for
me was the fifth lesson
uh obviously on a more mundane level not
at that
terrible and tragic uh situation but for
all of us
you know whatever pain or suffering that
we're that we're
experiencing the idea of having a goal
of having an objective having an
aim that we can strive for gives our
life
meaning and so that was the fifth the
fifth lesson
so take me back to the beginning of your
decision to to take to go on this israel
trail you're
you're about to embark on this two-month
700 mile very lonely solitary
and oftentimes dangerous journey uh
you're hoping to find
it sounds to me like you're hoping to
find some clarity as to you know the
current
situation the current emotional state
that you're in you end up finding that
clarity
mainly in the you know in the solitude
right in the in the different
in the in your in your head in your
thoughts where whether it's a metaphor
for the arab israeli conflict for this
acceptance or whether it's the cl or
acceptance was more the the cliff that
you had to cross but for the forgiveness
on the arab israeli conflict and this
idea that you know in order to really
have peace whether it's you know peace
at home or peace
with you know our neighbors we first
have to learn to forgive in the gut
and not not in the mind can you extract
a little bit about how we can
you know how can we again extrapolate
these to our everyday things how can we
you know besides just reading about it
and and
think about it but really comprehending
what's what's the core
issue and how we can then you know
investigate how we're dealing with it
well i think we can combine a few things
which are relevant for all of us i'm
sure you've read especially with this
series
uh that you've been you've been hosting
now for so long i'm sure you're familiar
with stephen covey's
uh the seven habits of highly effective
people and principles of leadership and
what have you
there's no question that that setting
goals are a very big part of that for
all of us
daily goals weekly uh monthly yearly
five-year goals lifetime goals etc
and from for i think for a lot of us
this issue of acceptance can be even on
the most simple
level whether you know you trip and
stumble physically
uh and injure yourself or your trip and
stumble in a relationship
or in uh in a work project and the
idea of recognizing you know in
the venture capital world there's an
understanding that
an interpreter who has failed in
uh in some sort of endeavor may be
a better ceo of the next company that
they start
than somebody who simply had a good idea
and is
doing a startup in other words failure
itself is something we learn from and
acceptance right
and humility uh both humility and
acceptance are a big part
of that um and i think when we talk
about leadership i
speak a little bit about this my book we
also we can go back to
to um uh moshe rabeno to moses
uh in leading the children of israel the
the
the defining characteristic of moses in
the bible
is his modesty his humility which is a
little bit counter-intuitive
because you expect a leader to be you
know out there charging uh
in front and telling people what to do
and thinking that they know it all
and yet i think for all of us that that
sense of modesty and understanding that
we don't know everything and that we're
just
a we're an important cog in a wheel but
we're just a small cog in the wheel
we're just
you know playing whatever role it is
that we're playing and everybody has an
important role to play i think
that's that's an important at least take
away that i had from
that first uh that first period in the
in the desert
connecting as it were to our people
wandering through the desert the
children of israel wandering through the
desert our prophets
um getting most of their inspiration in
the judean desert and elsewhere
um that kind of a connection for me kind
of brought all
together and it brings me back to this
idea of humility and
acceptance i i just love that if you
look back at your
other experiences you worked in
government in the private sector in the
public sector today you're still active
you know with with with the renewable
energy talk to me a little bit about how
you're seeing
you know things that perhaps before you
would
you would it would occupy your mind or
your emotions or
and that or you know would would cloud
your your ability to be a good leader
that now after this experience and after
writing this book and
and this really you know contemplation
you're you're able to
you know have much more clarity about it
shrug it off or just you know go beyond
it and say you know what
this is not that important right now i
can i can go past this
well it's funny because again the
combination of humility and acceptance
kind of brings us to that state of
recognizing or at least
trying to recognize what's really
important uh and prioritizing what's
really important and when you're out
there hiking the trail and you've got a
backpack and literally everything
your only possession the only things you
need are your water
and uh not even necessarily a change of
clothes but at least you know
a warm sleeping bag and with your needs
reduced to
such a basic kind of subsistence level
yes it gave me
great perspective and that's obviously
one of the things that that helped me
to to not just meet my challenge and get
over my sadness and my anguish
and my pain but also to look ahead
and the truth is there's also an element
of uh of understanding if we
are uh if we have that perspective
of um of
recognizing that you know not everything
is about us
then we also can be open to different
kinds of possibilities for ourselves
right and priority is that we weren't
necessarily
not that we take take them for granted
but you know i talk about the gratitude
i had for my friends and my family
i mean i i have always been a
communicator i've always been
a connector and and very connected with
my friends and family
um but the hike experience and these
learnings
basically made me even more so and put a
greater priority
um on on that the truth is it was true
in the business
in my business experience as well i
always
wanted and moved from different
businesses and back and forth into the
public
from the private sector into the public
sector because i wanted to do more
to do more good as it were but one of
the decisions i took towards the end of
the trail was
i was going to leave the position that i
was in and joined
this company doing renewable energy for
africa because
it was going to enable me to combine my
interest in business and profit
with an interest in doing something good
for the world
and doing something that i love at the
same time
and and somebody famous uh once shared
with
with me or somebody somebody close to me
my my wife now shared with me that
somebody famous once said
um find something that you love to do
and something that you're good at and
find a way to get paid for it
and there's a japanese there's a
japanese philosophy that kind of
combines those three
find something that you love to do and
that you're good at you can get paid for
with something that the world needs um
and so for me moving into building
renewable energy solar and wind
uh hydro projects in africa and some of
the poorest countries on the planet
uh really does um fill kind of all four
of those
categories i love that aria you know in
the short amount of time that we have
left i would love to pick your brain on
some
really key things that i should be
keeping in mind for myself as i
you know approach this world of venture
entrepreneurship and the things that i
want to be
and you know i want to be working on and
the challenges that i'll be
tackling with you know what are some
really key things you would say to a
young entrepreneur as they're just
starting their journey from you know the
wealth of challenges and experiences
you've accumulated
you know in your experience well
without question one would be this issue
of finding something that you love to do
obviously everybody needs to make a
living and
i suppose within the business world
everybody wants to find a
unicorn or be involved in some very
successful business
um but i think that that our generation
meaning my generation and now then your
generation the newer generations let's
say this
have come in the last few in the
maturity in the last few decades
recognize
that there's a lot more to life than
going to work and coming home and having
a nice car
and whether it's climate change or
whether it's equality or whether it's
addressing food scarcity or health
issues around the world
there's so much that technology and that
the business world can
offer to solve the world's problems
you know we call it in the impact
investment world we call it doing well
by doing good
uh and and this idea of bringing a
values lens to the business world is
something that i would definitely
continue to encourage the younger
generation for a very specific reason
because you you can invent you know the
most
terrific new technology or platform or
application or
software what have you um but in the end
you're not going to 10 or 20 or 30 years
with all your wealth
uh well um later feel the sense of
fulfillment or that you've contributed
to humanity
in the way that you will if that
technology or that platform or that
software
comes to serve a social good if it comes
to
to provide an answer to one of the
pressing social or health or
environmental or economic
i love that and i think that that that
sense of responsibility and
and maturity and taking ownership not
just of our career but taking ownership
of society and saying you know if you
have the
if you have that urge for urgency for
leadership and innovation then part of
that urgency and part of the
responsibility that you have innately
by being a leader is to be a responsible
leader and part of that responsible
leadership is not just for your own
team but it is how does your team affect
the rest of the world
and are you making the most positive
impact and obviously then it's always a
balance
uh but i think one thing that we've
learned is that it's very very possible
to balance those two things together
make a very positive impact
and be very successful and so
arya i really want to thank you for
coming on this show it was really really
fantastic
i have the most important question that
i have to ask which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um right right um so that's a difficult
one
mike yeah so i would say
um optimism uh is
is one definitely uh love
uh from every angle and
and i guess some communication
i'm a communicator i believe in
communication
thank you very very much this was
wonderful thank you for spending this
time with me
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you you too stay safe and stay
[Music]
sane